what's going on guys this is Rob and I
almost never make videos like this but I
was sitting here thinking and I was like
you know what youtubers which as far as
I'm aware almost no one's really made a
video like this and I feel a video like
this needs to be made so I'm going to
make this and I'll probably never do
anything like this again but I am coming
up close on a million subs which I'm
really excited about and my fans are the
reason why I've gotten it my hard work
their support has helped to culminate in
the channel reaching close to a million
subs hopefully we'll cross that point
sometime in the next few months but you
learn a lot of things on the road to 1
million you learn a lot of things on the
road to win Liam one of the very first
things you learn when it comes to
YouTube is the plan for the future
now I am NOT a lawyer I am NOT an
attorney I am NOT giving you legal
financial advice I might be giving you
legal advice all I'm telling you is
these are the things that I have learned
but I'm going to make a few assumptions
here one of the first assumption that
I'm going to make is that you are in a
position on YouTube where you have the
ability just not making money I'm not
talking about oh hey I can buy a new
pair a Nike Shox
I'm talking about money money I'm
talking about you sitting down saying
man I could quit my job yeah man like
okay I mean I'm making money or any
money on you - I'll make it cash you
know now I bet I'm willing to bet that
money's burning a hole in your pocket
I'm going to bet that money it's killing
you like you're just like man I can
spend that cash or like I've spilled
that money now if you're an mo here at
that position go on Metro go to San
Francisco for the weekend take your
significant other your boyfriend your
girlfriend your husband your wife
whatever the case may be go to Seattle
for the weekend get dinner get a steak
at an amazing history do that man you
know the place where you go when you sit
down and the person says I'm your server
my name is such-and-such and assisting
me today are two guys one guy will
refill your drinks another guy will give
you your food and your server will just
check in on you occasionally and see if
there's anything you need your server
has
as assistants go to that restaurant have
an amazing time have an amazing time
because when you get back my friend
you're getting down to brass tacks you
are going to sit down when you get back
and you're going to ask yourself some
very serious questions we were to say
where am I in life right now the Maya
college kid am i in college right now am
i I just got you know getting up seven
o'clock in the morning do I have it's
like ecology class at 9:00 a.m. I've got
a genetics class at 11:00 a.m. you know
you're gonna sit down you're gonna say
okay yeah what am I going to do I mean
I'm making money money I need you much
handles Brella I'm getting a few hundred
subs a day and turn through a few
thousand subs a day and my channel just
going to start growing like crazy money
is just going to keep going higher and
higher and higher do I really need a
college degree or they come on man I'm
making more money on YouTube now that I
would ever make with a college degree
and that's true man the money you can
make on YouTube would dwarf anything you
would make with a college degree there
are people with master's degrees that
will never see the kind of money you're
making on YouTube maybe you have a
full-time job right here you get up
several o'clock in the morning get your
cup of coffee
eat up an animated food go into the
bathroom shower and shave and you
get out get dressed and get your car you
drive to your job where you sit in your
cubicle for eight hours Diane for when
you can get home and playful rising zero
dog record yourself upload it to youtube
and watch that cash roll in you're
probably asking yourself do I really
need that job do I really really need
that you know I imagine you think about
probably leaving why don't you make it a
challenge other you're probably yielding
about quitting your job no you're making
you offer you that job
you don't need your boss giving you
asking you about TPS reports let me tell
you something man
if you leave college if you leave your
full-time job you are what weed and the
business call a buffoon a fool in India
a you want to know why because
YouTube won't last forever let me ask
you something what happens if you have a
gaming channel and you're super super
popular but then gaming stops being
popular on YouTube what I was going to
have an ear cut or isn't it as if the
people that want your content now grow
up and the min people who would come in
to fill their place are farewell then
your views you start your views your
thoughts go and then your view start
going down faster than Miley
like your views just take they take like
Britney Spears career rme this is gone
in the blink of an eye well then where's
the money
there's nobody where's where's the huge
future that you sloppy yourself where's
that where that has gone up in smoke
it's disappeared nowhere to be seen or
heard from again so here you are no
money no job but if you've stayed at
that full-time Janabi would have been
like man I've got my steady paycheck
what bills get paid my rent gets paid
like a Chili's get paid I've got
retirement 401k for free beneath
whatever skin I've got Dennis it helped
not the greatest what it works
yeah what's necessary I go to the doctor
go pay a $10 copay to a Telugu okay you
got dental insurance in case you ever
have kids one of these braces you got
eye insurance in case you need to get
some glasses like these yeah these
glasses by the way don't tell me they're
not I know they are if you are in
college oh man market sucks for kids
with college results what happens when
that market comes back and suddenly
there's a need for people with college
degrees we're better off for it you got
a degree to your name don't leave
college and don't leave your job instead
what you're going to do is you are going
to go find a financial advisor
you're going to go find someone who
specializes in making sure that people
don't go the way of MC Hammer you're
going to go five
my dreams but hey look man here's what I
want to do is go say okay cool what do
you wanted you and you're going to be
able to tell them what you want to do
you want to know why because you sat
down and you made a plan you said hey
look I'm a single guy a single girl
where I'm a married man
I'm a married woman I've got a family of
the case maybe I want the village I want
to huge amount of stability and the best
way to do that is to buy a home so you
say I want to buy a house so I don't
want a mortgage if I don't have to get
one I mean I guess I could get one if I
needed to but I want to be able to buy a
house and cash cash money son channa
come in like I want a house that I own
outright and you tell your financial
adviser that you're one actual registers
okay well how much money you make
anything man I make it Miss amount of
money a month if I last your visors
gonna be like holy that's the kind
of money you're pulling down son damn
and you can be like yeah that's the kind
of money to have god they say okay but
then here are the things you need to do
if you have kids you're going to say I
want my kids to not have to worry about
student loan debt maybe the economy
never really gets back to where it was
before maybe there's never really a huge
market for people in bachelor's degrees
you know maybe it's never going to be
one of those situations where things
were before the economy tanked in 2008
where you're going to sit down and
you're going to say you know I gotta ask
the question if a bachelor's degree is
what a high school degree used to be
worth well then what's the high school
to rework them now so you're going to
say if my kid is going to have a
bachelor's degree and be struggling
enough as it is do I really want to add
student loan debt to that those who I
want to be able to go to my kid and say
hey look your college is paid all you
have to do is just not screw up because
if you do your college won't be paid for
and you're going to have to work so you
go to your financial advisor say hey
look cooler have money set aside so then
my kids can go to college you go to your
financial advisor and you say you know I
want to have this kind of stability so
that when the time comes where I can
successfully leave my job when the time
comes when I do have money going into my
retirement when the time comes where I
can walk away from all that and enjoy
luxury I don't have to worry that this
YouTube comes crashing down then it all
goes away you want to sit down and you
want to be able to say I'm going to be
able to leave my job and I want to go on
vacations I want to upload videos on
- band schedule them out two weeks ahead
of time so that my family and I we can
go to Disneyworld
do not be one of these youtubers that
get so overwhelmed with their success
that gets so carried away with how
successful they can be that you just
throw it all down the drain that you
leap before you look be smart with the
kind of income that you're making now
what's the next thing do you do lemare
you do I mean you've got the finance
stuff out of way right this videos
turning out to be kind of lengthy but
you got the finance stuff out of the way
all right but what do you do that I mean
you know you want to keep your channel
growing right here yeah because you sit
down and say okay look look like it's
entirely possible that in five years or
something like that the views on my
channel will drop off whatever for
whatever reason the interest just won't
be there or maybe interest in YouTube
gaming goes away maybe you feel like me
YouTube and common grantors some comic
books will eventually go away and you
want to have other ways to make up for
that you want to have other revenue
source you want to have the ability to
to have other projects on the side or
maybe you just want to do something
greater maybe you're like me right you
sat down one day and you watched the
chef's table are Netflix and you said oh
my god the cinematography on this is
insane I want to do that but I want the
videos to be about geek culture icons
about Stan Lee about like markiplier or
about like you know some other youtubers
out there who was just huge icons Yaya
Han and the realm of cosplay people who
are just icons and geek culture like
recognizable names you say I want to
make videos like that about documentary
so you say okay look I want to start
making the direction to do that but your
question is how I don't know how to do
stuff like that I mean there are people
out there who do but I mean I don't know
how to do stuff like that well the first
step to being able to make contacts the
first step to being able to talk to
people is not to be a dick alright
do not get on Twitter and start Lam
fasting people do not get in your videos
and start talking trash to people you
want to know why because you have to
treat your YouTube channel like every
video that you upload that everything
you say on Twitter is heard by the world
conduct yourself appropriately like a
reasonable human being now maybe you're
going for that market of drama
maybe you're going for that market of
talking down to people maybe you're
going for that market of causing
problems and that markets there but let
me ask you this when the time comes when
that markets not there who's going to be
willing to lend you are helping it you
pissed off everybody if you say hey look
like you guys yeah I'm trying to break
into new markets can you tell me how
people are gonna be like yeah I'm over
you
you're that jerk who was talking bad
about me on Twitter I saw your video
where you called me out yeah good job on
your hundred thousand views best of luck
to you in the future
Network and make friends one of the best
pieces of advice that ones best pieces
of advice that I ever got was from a guy
named seananners when I first started
getting into YouTube I was watching all
these different videos all these
different you know pieces of constant
guy named hutch you know Shawn 0-7 too
late I think this is actually a YouTube
channel he got me into call of duty from
his channel I found guys like Blaine
truth I found guys like Excalibur's
sandy ravaged the mark of Jay the trout
91 a moody Swede
but seananners was always my favorite
now eventually I ended up go starting my
own YouTube channel one that I have now
comments explain one of the first things
I did was I sent between up tweet of CNN
turns that I said I'm trying to start a
YouTube channel how do I grow his
response network and make friends
forward changed my life so I
turned around and I started networking
and I started making friends I hit up a
guy named comic story and said hey do
you want to start a YouTube channel run
sort of podcast and upcoming books and
he responded some three or four days
later I don't think he was actually
going to answer what he did we started a
podcast called the weekly poll we reach
that we grab the third guy name is Sal
from a YouTube channel called trolley
pop and the rest of history
[Music]
networking makes right
people that you pissed off are not going
to be inclined to help me now you might
look at this me might say so you're
telling me that I need to curtail my
clock and you're telling me that I can't
speak my mind and I can't say the things
that I want to I can't be whoever it is
and I want you oh you can
yeah then drag them a speech man you've
got freedom of speech you can say
whatever you want to you can make a
youtube video lambaste in youtube you
can make a youtube video tearing down
every youtuber that's ever been bigger
than you you can make youtube videos or
just don't do anything but espouse
negativity you have the freedom to do
that you also have the freedom to deal
with the consequences of it
so make your own decisions do what you
want to do I'm just saying the best
chance for you to have a career outside
of YouTube is to have friends that will
help you along that path case in point a
buddy of mine made a YouTube video who
this buddy's name isn't still relevant
and what the YouTube video was about is
irrelevant and who it was that he was
talking to is irrelevant but he made a
youtube video talking to a particular
person addressing something about that
particular person that he didn't like
this particular person made his Twitter
account private and the result was that
he and I had this great big huge
conversation I said let me tell you
something let me ask you this you want
to branch out of YouTube right he said
yeah and I said okay what happens if the
person that you lambasted who made their
Twitter account private what happens if
you want to branch out into like another
other place like screen junkies or
something like that and this person that
you kiss off could have been your
contact to get you at a screen jumping
not only that will that person not get
you in to screen junkies when that
person meets with screen junkies
whenever there's kind of hanging out and
is talking at cons like a lot of
different people to know screen junkies
brings up a video where they say hey man
like this guy I made a video like was
that about you and the guys like yeah
man he made a video about me here's what
he said you won't believe what he said
that guy's a dick did your screen
junkies contact is gone so much for you
opportunity that's just the way goes
that's the way the games played
you're free to say whatever you want to
just recognize that you have to treat
your YouTube channel like everybody in
the world
everybody in the world your online
presence is everyone don't be a jerk
be true to yourself be honest about who
you are but understand a time will come
when you may need the help of others and
when that time comes you want to make
sure that you didn't offend them you
want to make sure you didn't piss them
off that you didn't send them running
you want to make sure that they're going
to be willing to help you that you can
say look I can help you will you help me
and they'll be receptive to that but any
of it guys let's forget I just kind of
fill out a few thoughts here with
regards to say you know a little little
tidbits little things that I've learned
along the road to youtube and my road 1
million subscribers but anything event
if you guys you're new here to comment
explaining sure you guys hit the sub let
me become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and it will catch you all later
please
[Music]
you